fans who tuned in to see Melissa Roush
on the new Night Court were shocked when
the actress opened her mouth and didn't
squeak like her Big Bang Theory
character Bernadette here's what they
had to say while everyone remembers The
Big Bang Theory as a smash hit sitcom it
didn't start out that way initially
receiving mixed reviews the series came
into its own around season 3 when the
series introduced two new recurring
characters neurobiologist Amy Farah
Fowler played by Mayim Bialik and
budding microbiologist Bernadette
rostenkowski played by Melissa Rauch the
two became series regulars starting with
season four Bernadette joined the series
as Penny's co-worker at the Cheesecake
Factory but she soon became a
full-fledged member of the group and a
love interest to Howard Roush brought a
pint-sized punch to the role and quickly
emerged as a fan favorite roush's
Bernadette immediately stood out because
of her high-pitched voice this is
adrenaline we're gonna have to inject it
into his heart we are you are I'm not
strong enough to get it through his
chest plate and we've only got one shot
Roush is actually quite an accomplished
voice actor contributing her abilities
to a number of animated projects
including Batman and Harley Quinn and
Ice Age Collision Course since the Big
Bang Theory wrapped in 2019 Roush has
kept busy her biggest post Big Bang
Theory project is starring in the brand
new Night Court reboot which she also
produces alongside her husband Winston
Roush on the show Roush plays judge Abby
Stone the daughter of Harry Stone the
judge from the original Night Court from
the 80s and early 90s she presides over
the Manhattan Criminal Court's night
shift joined by original series Star
John Larroquette the reboot is an
unabashed hit so far it's January 17th
Premiere racked up the highest total
viewers for a comedy Premiere since the
Connors in 2018 according to Yahoo while
fans are excited to see the actress who
played Bernadette on the small screen
some Big Bang Theory loyalists are
having trouble getting used to roush's
normal speaking voice I moved here for a
job
I am the new Night Court Judge one
tweeted enjoyed the new Night Court last
night just adjusting to Melissa roush's
non-burnadet voice some viewers were
shocked to discover that Bernadette's
speaking voice was different from
roush's one wrote oh my God I really
thought Melissa Roush talked just like
Bernadette from Big Bang Theory LOL as
is often the case it's tough for fans to
separate the actor from her best known
role some even referred to Roush as her
Big Bang Theory character's name one
tweeted Bernadette does a good job as
Harry's daughter while some fans of the
original Night Court were critical of
the new series many other responses were
very positive one fan tweeted directly
to Roush referring to the actor who
played the original Judge Stone such a
great start to night court and a great
tribute to the late great Harry Anderson
with night courts set to air weekly on
NBC fans will get plenty of
opportunities to adjust to roush's lower
pitched voice what's surprising is that
Roush wasn't expected to star in the
reboot at first deadline reported that
Rao Shu grew up watching the original
sitcom approached Warner Brothers
television with the idea for the Legacy
sequel series herself she didn't intend
to make it a project for herself to star
in but it just turned out that way in an
exclusive interview with Looper Roush
said she hopes there's plenty in the new
series for all types of viewers
explaining for people who love the
original they're so much there for them
but then people who've never seen the
show before could come in without any
prior knowledge and enjoy it without
having to know anything about what once
was
[Music]